so this sample it's a very very
interesting sample it's arsenic okay so
this is mathie quality arsenic so
arsenic used to be much more common in
the community than it is nowadays it was
used as a pigment for in the 19th
century for green wallpaper contained
copper arsenate and because there
weren't any other good green pigments to
make the wallpaper and when the rooms
were damp and the Victorians didn't like
opening the windows in their rooms then
mold would grow on the wall and because
arsenic is poisonous to most life forms
the mold would convert the arsenic into
a volatile compound tri methyl arsène
and the tri methyl our scene went into
the air and several people were killed
by the arsenic coming from their
wallpaper now actually because we all
know is very toxic and there have been a
number of very high-profile and very
famous cases of people that have
poisoned perhaps their partners or their
business partners using arsenic okay so
I'm going to very carefully take this
vial out this is very carefully he
knocks it really hard arsenic was also
used quite widely by people to dispose
of husbands wives lovers though now it
is much less common it is used in the
electronics industry for making deposits
em for getting electronic properties for
making transistors and also it is still
sometimes used for feeding for
medication for feeding to livestock it's
only quite in recently that the use of
arsenic has been banned as an additive
to chicken feed in the United States so
here you see the arsenic powder okay now
this is a metallic very dark metal but
I'm not going to open this because like
I said it's very very toxic very dark
metallic sample you can see very
fine powder in the bottom of this file
now I'm going to put this back in before
I get it on my skin because the very
toxic material I don't want to expose
myself